there's a lot of people who have an
opinion about bitcoin some people like
it and some people don't but just
recently we saw a bunch of human right
advocates come together and say well
there might be another aspect of bitcoin
that you're not considering as we saw in
this cnbc article they went ahead and
they laid out these human right
advocates telling congress bitcoin is
essential in countries with collapsing
currencies mackenzie sigelos went ahead
and covered it and said 21 human rights
supporters from 20 different countries
sent the letter and they said that they
rely on bitcoin and stable coins that
allow the trading in and out of crypto
without going through a bank as having
tens of millions of others living under
authoritarian regimes or unstable
economies mackenzie went on to state
that beyond their use in trading and
speculative investing bitcoin has seen
increased utility in recent months as
people from numerous different countries
sent tens of millions of dollars to
ukraine via crypto payment rails to
support the war effort and the defense
against russia and then lastly
ukrainians were fleeing the country they
were able to take their money with them
in the form of cryptocurrency stored on
a usb drive a similar narrative played
out in afghanistan in august when the
taliban took over the country and the
banks were closed down there now of
course not everyone actually believes
this narrative not everyone is a
proponent of bitcoin we've got an
engineer over from amazon who's a critic
he says that the technology isn't very
good and there's a culture of sleaze and
rug pulls and nfts and ponzis now tim
bray he actually might be onto something
but that stuff's different than bitcoin
nobody's rug pulling bitcoin now of
course there's plenty of critics but
bitcoin's been adopted by 150 million
people around the world bitcoin is a
decentralized digital currency it's
providing real utility and it can be
seen as why in these countries where
there's collapsing currencies or there's
geopolitical uncertainty why bitcoin is
so valuable alex gladstein from the
human rights foundation he followed it
up and he said if the congress intends
to restrict the ability of americans to
use bitcoin it needs to know that this
is going to have significant negative
effects for the millions of people who
rely on it worldwide ultimately bitcoin
is a piece of software it's literally
words written in a database but that
software is providing incredible value
to tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions of people around the world
bitcoin is a decentralized digital
currency that is not controlled by
anyone no one can confiscate it from you
and no one can prevent you from sending
it to anyone else that may sound like a
small little idea but when you put it on
the backdrop of macro issues collapsing
currencies and geopolitical conflict
bitcoin becomes an imperative part of
the everyday life of humans around the
world and naturally we need to have
human rights advocates talking about
this educating people and making sure
that congress and other organizations
realize exactly how important bitcoin is
to the global world hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time